IF ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," IT’S WEIRD TO SAY IT
BUT THIS IS THE LAST DAY OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP
COME OF THE SAD THING TO FACE
AFTER FOUR YEARS.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF YOU DIDN’T
SUPPORT A DONALD TRUMP, IF YOU
ARE ONE THE OF THE MANY OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL CLASS WHO MADE
HATING DONALD TRUMP A CENTER OF
YOUR LIFE, THIS IS GOT TO BE A
PRETTY GOOD DAY FOR YOU -- YOU
WON.
YOUR PARTY NOW HAS CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING.
TOMORROW AFTERNOON, DONALD TRUMP
WILL BE GONE FOR GOOD, YOU GOT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANTED.
YOU SHOULD BE THRILLED ABOUT
THAT, YOU WANT TO BE
CELEBRATING, BUT THEY ARE NOT
CELEBRATING.
THAT’S A REMARKABLE THING.
NO ONE IN THE TONIGHT, THEY ARE
ANGRIER THAN EVER.
INSTEAD OF TAKING VICTORY LAPS,
THEY ARE PLOTTING REVENGE
AGAINST THE PEOPLE THEY JUST
BEAT, THEY ARE THINKING OF NEW
WAYS TO INJURE AND HUMILIATE AND
DEGRADE THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS, MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO WORK AGAIN, THROW
THEM IN JAIL, DESTROY THEIR
LIVES.
IT’S HARD TO DESCRIBE HOW WEIRD
AND STRANGE AND AWFUL THIS IS TO
WATCH.
IMAGINE WINNING A TENNIS MATCH
IN STRAIGHT SETS AND IMMEDIATELY
LEAPING OVER THE NET AND
SMASHING YOUR OPPONENT IN THE
FACE WITH YOUR RACKET.
IT WASN’T ENOUGH FOR YOU TO WIN,
YOU HAD TO INFLICT PHYSICAL
PAIN, YOU COULDN’T BE HAPPY
UNTIL ANOTHER HUMAN BEING
SCREAMED IN AGONY.
IF WHAT KIND OF PERSON WOULD DO
THAT?
THE KIND OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WATCHING NOW, THE KIND OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE EVEN MORE VICIOUS WHEN
THEY WIN.
IF THE LEADERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE NOW
DECIDED THAT 74 MILLION TRUMP
VOTERS WERE JUST WRONG OR
MISGUIDED, THEY DIDN’T JUST
SIMPLY BACK THE WRONG GUY OR
HAVE INCORRECT OPINIONS OR FAIL
TO SEE THE OBVIOUS TRUTHS -- NO.
THE THREAT THEY POSE IS GRAVER
AND MORE SERIOUS, MORE
DANGEROUS.
THESE 74 MILLION TRUMP VOTERS
ARE IN FACT TERRORISTS.
THEY ARE A LOOMING PHYSICAL
THREATS TO THE REST OF US AND WE
MUST DEAL WITH THEM IN THE WAY
THAT YOU DEAL WITH THREATS LIKE
THAT -- EXISTENTIAL THREATS TO
THE NATION.
SADDAM HUSSEIN, KIM JONG UN,
DONALD TRUMP’S VOTERS.
FOR YEARS THEY TOLD US THIS
COUNTRY HAD BEEN INFILTRATED BY
RUSSIAN SPIES BUT NOW WE KNOW
IT’S WORSE THAN THAT.
THE REAL THREAT, THE ACTUAL
ENEMY IS WITHIN, IN THE END IT
ALWAYS IS.
74 MILLION DEVIATIONS WORK IN
OUR MIDST, THEY LOOK LIKE NORMAL
PEOPLE BUT DO NOT BE DECEIVED.
THEY ARE TROTSKY HEIGHTS, THEY
ARE WRECKERS, IT WILL TAKE A WAR
TO ROOT THEM OUT, A WAR ON OUR
OWN PEOPLE.
TO MAKE THAT POINT IS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS MARSHALED MILITARY LEADERS
TO DELIVER THE NEWS, THEY ARE
THE PARTY’S SPOKESMAN.
GENERAL STANLEY McCHRYSTAL IS
AMONG THEM, HE IS THE STRATEGIC
GENIUS WHO CAN TAKE CREDIT IF
YOU CAN CALL IT THAT FOR RUNNING
THE LONGEST LOSING WAR IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, THE ONE IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE WAR THAT’S
STILL GOING.
McCHRYSTAL TOOK A BREAK FROM
COLLECTING CORPORATE DIRECTORS
FEES TO NOTE THAT BASED ON HIS
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE MISMANAGING
FOREIGN POLICY, TRUMP VOTERS
LOOK AN AWFUL LOT LIKE
TERRORISTS, AN AWFUL LOT.
"I DID SEE A SIMILAR DYNAMIC OF
THE EVOLUTION OF AL QAEDA IN
IRAQ.
IF YOU WERE A WHOLE GENERATION
OF ANGRY ARAB YOUTH WITH VERY
POOR PROSPECTS FOLLOWED A VERY
POWERFUL LEADER WHO PROMISED TO
TAKE THEM BACK TO A TIME, TO A
BETTER PLACE AND HE LED THEM TO
AEMBRACE AN IDEOLOGY THAT
JUSTIFIED THEIR VIOLENCE.
THIS IS NOW HAPPENING IN AMERICA
AMERICA" AL QAEDA IN AMERICA.
THANKS, STAN.
SOMETIME WHEN YOU CAN MANAGE TO
SPEND A MOMENT FROM GETTING RICH
FOR YOUR FAILURES IN AMERICA’S
DECLINE, WE WOULD LOVE TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT DID HAPPEN IN
AFGHANISTAN, WHEN YOU HAVE TIME.
UNTIL THEN, ANDY McCABE WOULD
LIKE TO PUT A FINER POINT ON THE
MATTER, HE IS THE FORMER
HIGH-LEVEL FBI OFFICIAL WHO WAS
CANNED FOR LYING AND CORRUPTION,
A MODEL FEDERAL EMPLOYEE.
WHEN HE SPEAKS YOU CAN HEAR THE
MORAL AUTHORITY IN HIS VOICE,
GRAVELLY AND RESIDENT LIKE
CIGARETTE SMOKE, YOU’RE GOING TO
WANT TO LISTEN CAREFULLY TO WHAT
HE HAS TO SAY.
ACCORDING TO HIS CONSIDERED
JUDGMENT, DONALD TRUMP’S VOTERS
ARE VERY MUCH VERY MUCH LIKE
ISIS, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WHEN WE LOOKED AT THOSE
AMERICANS WHO TRAVELED TO SYRIA
FOR THE PURPOSE OF JOINING THE
ISLAMIC STATE, WHEN YOU PUT ALL
THOSE FACES AND NAMES DOWN IN
ONE PLACE, YOU HAD DOCTORS,
LAWYERS -- SOME PEOPLE ARE VERY
VULNERABLE AND DRAWN INTO THAT
CORE LIE OF ANY EXTREMIST
MOVEMENT AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW WITH THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S.
>> Tucker: WEIGHT.
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIAL ANDY McCABE IS
TELLING US THEY ARE LIKE ISIS --
ISLAMIC STATE IN SYRIA?
AREN’T OF THOSE THE WILD EYED
LUNATICS WHO BEHEADED
JOURNALISTS AND VIDEOTAPE
THEMSELVES DOING IT?
THAT’S TERRIFYING.
THAT’S RIGHT,
MR. AND MRS. AMERICA -- WHAT WE
DIDN’T TELL YOU BEFORE WAS THAT
ISIS WAS FOR DONALD TRUMP,
THAT’S WHEN YOU’RE MURDERING SO
MANY PEOPLE, THEY WERE THE
SYRIAN BRANCH OF MAGA, YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD SOME KIND OF ISLAMIC
THING, THAT IS RACIST -- IT’S
DONALD TRUMP ALL ALONG.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY, IN DALLAS AND SARASOTA
AND NEWPORT BEACH, EVERYWHERE --
HIDING IN PLAIN SIGHT GOD KNOWS
WHAT THEY WILL DO NEXT --
ACTUALLY WE DO KNOW, ANOTHER
9/11!
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE PLANNING ON
THAT’S WHY WE NEED A NEW 9/11
COMMISSION TO ROOT THEM OUT BUT
THANKFULLY COMMANDER PELOSI IS
PLANNING ONE RIGHT NOW, WATCH.
>> THERE IS A STRONG INTEREST IN
A 9/11 TYPE COMMISSION.
>> KEEP LOOKING AT A 9/11 STYLE
COMMISSION TO GET TO ALL OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> THEY NEED A 9/11 TYPE
COMMISSION OF INQUIRY.
>> ALONG THE LINES OF A 9/11
COMMISSION.
>> A 9/11 TYPE COMMISSION.
>> AND THE DEPENDENT 9/11 STYLE
COMMISSION WILL LOOK AT.
>> THIS IS A BIG ENOUGH THREAT,
AN ATTACK ON THE CENTER OF OUR
DEMOCRACY THAT IS GOING TO NEED
A LOOK THAT SPANS BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT, SOMETHING CLOSER TO
A 9/11 COMMISSION.
>> Tucker: I THINK WE KNOW
THEY ARE ON THE SAME EMAIL
CHAIN -- DID YOU HEAR JIM COMEY,
ANOTHER NOTED MORAL AUTHORITY,
WHAT HE TOLD YOU IS THAT WHAT
HAPPENED IN WASHINGTON ON
JANUARY 6, THE CHEWBACCA GUY
STUMBLING AROUND THE HOUSE FLOOR
AND ALL OF IT, THAT WAS THIS
GENERATIONS 9/11.
AND IN FACT THE MAGNITUDE OF
THAT ATROCITY BEGS FOR A BETTER
DAY HIM -- FOR NOW ON WE ARE
GOING TO CALL IT 1/6.
YOUR GRANDCHILDREN WILL GET THE
DAY OFF FROM SCHOOL EVERY
JANUARY 6 IN REMEMBRANCE OF THE
HORROR THAT TOOK PLACE -- LET’S
CALL IT INSURRECTION DAY BECAUSE
HONESTLY, THAT’S WHAT IT WAS.
>> THE PRESIDENT INCITED
INSURRECTION AGAINST CONGRESS TO
PREVENT A PEACEFUL TRANSITION OF
POWER.
>> AND THEN HE SAT BACK AND
WATCH THE INSURRECTION.
>> INSURRECTION, A VIOLENT MOB.
>> WHITE SUPREMACIST PRESIDENT
WHO INCITED A WHITE SUPREMACIST
INSURRECTION, INSURRECTION
AGAINST OUR GOVERNMENT.
>> THE VIOLENT ATTACK ON THE
U.S. CAPITOL WAS AN ACT OF
INSURRECTION.
>> INSURRECTION THAT VIOLATE THE
SANCTITY OF THE PEOPLE’S
CAPITAL.
>> THIS WAS NOT A PROTEST, THIS
WAS ON INSURRECTION.
>> Tucker: BRUCE WILLIS IN
"INSURRECTION DAY."
IT’S NOT A JOKE.
ACCORDING TO THE HONORABLE JIM
McGOVERN AND EVERYONE ELSE YOU
SAW ON THE SCREEN, THIS WAS NOT
A PROTEST HOW DARE YOU CALL IT
THAT -- THIS WAS INSURRECTION,
WRITE THAT 100 TIMES ON THE
BOARD AND DON’T FORGET
INSURRECTION -- INSURRECTION.
LEARN IT, LOVE IT.
BUT YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW WHAT AN
INSURRECTION IS NOT -- FOR
EXAMPLE, 28 PEOPLE ARRESTED AT A
VIOLENT PROTEST IN NEW YORK, NOT
ON BEHALF OF DONALD TRUMP, THOSE
PEOPLE ATTACKED POLICE OFFICERS,
A BUNCH OF THEM WENT TO JAIL --
BUT KNOW THIS, WHERE THEY
INSURRECTION AT THE TIME?
THEY WEREN’T BECAUSE THEY
WEREN’T RACISTS, ONLY RACISTS
CAN DO IT, LISTEN CAREFULLY TO
CONGRESSMAN AYANNA PRESSLEY
EXPLAIN.
>> THE THREAT OF WHITE SUPREMACY
LOOMS LARGE AND IT IS TRAGIC
THAT IT TOOK AT THIS
INSURRECTION, THIS ATTEMPT TO
INTERRUPT THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER AND MOREOVER, INJURY
AND LOSS OF LIFE FOR MANY TO
APPRECIATE JUST HOW FORMIDABLE
THE THREAT OF WHITE SUPREME AS
HE IS.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A TOUGH
ONE, WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
INSURRECTIONIST’S LIKE THAT?
INSURRECTION LISTS WHO ARE ALSO
WHITE SUPREMACISTS AS THEY
ALWAYS ARE BUT NOT -- AND HERE’S
THE TRICKY PART -- IN SOME CASES
EVEN WHITE.
YOU HAVE NONWHITE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, THAT’S VERY TOUGH.
THESE ARE HARD CASES, YOU NEED
TO REEDUCATE PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
POSSIBLY IN CAMPS.
REEDUCATION CAMPS IF YOU WILL.
YOU MUST DEPROGRAM THEM FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE REST OF US.
THANKFULLY SANDY CORTEZ HAS BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THIS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME, SINCE SHE WAS A CHILD
GROWING UP IN LEAFY
WESTCHESTER COUNTY.
AT SOME LITTLE GIRL PLAYS WITH
DOLLS BUT SHE PUT HER BARBIES IN
A SECURE ENCLOSURE AND
REEDUCATED THEM BECAUSE THEY
WERE THINKING BAD THINGS,
FORBIDDEN THINGS.
SANDY CORTEZ KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
TO DO NOW.
>> WE HAD A PROGRAM ADDRESSING
WHITE SUPREMACISTS -- WE HAD
FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT WENT
TOWARDS FUNDING ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THESE THAT THE RADICALIZED
PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PULLED THE PLUG.
ON FEDERAL FUNDING FOR SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS.
ONE THING THAT WE KNOW IS WE
HAVE TO GET THAT FUNDING RIGHT
BACK UP AND WE PROBABLY NEED TO
DOUBLE, TRIPLE, QUADRUPLE, OR
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THESE
DERADICALIZATION PROGRAMS.
>> Tucker: BAD BARBIE -- THOSE
ARE NAUGHTY THOUGHTS!
THIS FEDERAL PROGRAM WILL
DEPROGRAM YOU.
YOU LISTEN TO THAT AND YOU
REALIZE THE TOTALITARIAN
INSTINCT IS ALWAYS THE SAME --
ALWAYS.
ONLY THE NAMES OF THE DICTATORS
CHANGE.
FIRST YOU STRIP PEOPLE OF THE
RIGHT TO SPEAK OUT LOUD
HONESTLY, THEN YOU PREVENT THEM
FROM DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES, THEN BECAUSE YOU
CAN, YOU FORCE THEM AT GUNPOINT
TO READ YOUR CATECHISM, TO
ACCEPT YOUR ORTHODOXY.
YOU WONDER IF SANDY CORTEZ PLANS
TO MAKE IT FROM VOTERS SIGNED
WRITTEN STATEMENTS AFFIRMING
THEY HAVE BEEN DEPROGRAMMED --
OF COURSE, THAT’S ALWAYS PART OF
THE PROCESS.
THE SCARY THING IS THAT’S WHERE
WE’RE HEADING, SANDY CORTEZ AND
HER FRIENDS ARE NO LONGER A
FRINGE ELEMENT WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY -- JOE BIDEN
RAN AS A MODERATE, PEOPLE VOTED
FOR HIM BECAUSE HE THOUGHT THEY
WAS BUT HIS VICTORY AS A VICTORY
FOR SANDY CORTEZ, THEY ARE
CLOSER NOW THAN THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN TO TAKING CONTROL, THE
REASON FOR THAT IS VERY SIMPLE.
THERE IS A MASSIVE POWER VACUUM
AT THE CENTER OF THIS INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION, THE WOMAN TAKES
POWER TOMORROW.
JOE BIDEN IS FADING, THAT IS NOT
A PERSONAL ATTACK ON JOE BIDEN,
IT IS REAL.
HE IS NOT CAPABLE OF RUNNING THE
GOVERNMENT OR PUSHING BACK ON
THE RADICALS AND HIS PARTY, THE
PEOPLE AROUND JOE BIDEN KNOW
THIS VERY WELL AND THAT INCLUDES
PEOPLE VERY CLOSE TO HIM
INCLUDING HIS RELATIVES.
PEOPLE WHO LOVE JOE BIDEN WERE
UPSET WHEN HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT,
THEY KNOW HE CAN’T DO THE JOB
AND THEY ARE VERY WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT -- THAT IS NOT
SPECULATION, THEY HAVE SAID SO
OUT LOUD AND NO HONEST PERSON IN
JOE BIDEN’S ORBIT WILL DENY THIS
THIS.
THE QUESTION IS WHO WILL FILL
THE POWER VACUUM WITHIN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION -- THERE
ARE STILL AND WE ARE BEING AS
HONEST AS WE CAN BE, THERE ARE
STILL REASONABLE PEOPLE WITHIN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A STAKE IN THIS
COUNTRY, PEOPLE WHO DON’T WANT
TO DESTROY IT AND NOW IS THE
TIME FOR THOSE PEOPLE, THE
REASONABLE PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO STEP UP
FORCEFULLY AND CALL OFF THE WAR
THEIR PARTY IS PLANNING ON
MILLIONS OF FELLOW AMERICANS.
IT IS MORE THEY ARE PLANNING, A
9/11 COMMISSION, BLANKET
CENSORSHIP, MASS ARRESTS,
DEPROGRAMMING.
THESE ARE NOT SUBTLE INDICATORS,
THESE ARE FIRE ALARMS AND
EVERYONE CAN SEE THEM.
NO ONE SEEMS TO CARE AT THE
MOMENT.
IN THE LAST WEEK CNN AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAVE
CALLED FOR FOX NEWS TO BE SHUT
DOWN BY FORCE -- WHY?
THEY DON’T LIKE OUR VIEWS SO WE
SHOULD BE BANNED.
IN A NORMAL COUNTRY, REASONABLE
PEOPLE INCLUDING OTHER
JOURNALISTS MIGHT STAND UP AND
SAY "HOLD ON, CENSORSHIP IS
WRONG.
CENSORSHIP ONLY SERVES THE
POWERFUL."
THEY HAVE SAID NOTHING BECAUSE
THEY AGREE.
MEANWHILE OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
BECOME OPENLY AUTHORITARIAN AND
NO ONE PUSHES BACK.
D.C. MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER SAID
SHE WOULD LIKE THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO PLACE CREW
SERVED MACHINE GUNS, BELT FED
.50-CALIBER AROUND THE CITY,
THIS IN ADDITION TO 26,000
FEDERAL TROOPS, MORE THAN
ABRAHAM LINCOLN HAD DEFENDING
THE CAPITAL IN 1864.
BUT WE NEED THOSE BECAUSE TRUMP
VOTERS ARE THAT DANGEROUS.
WHAT IS THE MASSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROFESSIONAL
LIBERTARIANS SAY ABOUT THIS?
NOTHING, THEY WERE SILENT.
WHAT DID MITCH McCONNELL SAY,
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER OF THE
SENATE?
NOTHING, HE WAS TOO BUSY
ATTACKING TRUMP VOTERS FOR BEING
THE REAL THREAT.
OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ON THE
OTHER SIDE POUR OFF THE MASK
COMPLETELY AND LAUNCHED INTO
OPEN RACE HATE ON TELEVISION,
THAT’S NOT AN EXAGGERATION, WE
WISH IT WAS, HERE IS CONGRESSMAN
JABBAR MOMENT EXPLAINING THE
REAL PROBLEM WITH THIS COUNTRY
IS WHITE PEOPLE, THE THREAT TO
PROGRESS.
>> THIS IS A CHANCE FOR ALL OF
US IN CONGRESS TO BEGIN AT A NEW
BASELINE.
STOP SPREADING THE MYTH OF
AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM AND
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THIS IS
EXACTLY WHO WE ARE AND THIS IS
EXACTLY WHO WE’VE BEEN
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY’S HISTORY
HISTORY.
WHENEVER THERE IS A SOCIAL
PROGRESS, THERE IS WHITE
BACKLASH.
>> Tucker: THE STORY HERE IS
NOT THAT ONE MEMBER OF CONGRESS
SAID THIS ON TELEVISION, THE
STORY IS THAT MANY MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND MEMBERS OF OUR
MEDIA SAY THIS ON TELEVISION
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
ATTACK HUGE GROUPS OF AMERICANS
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR SKIN COLOR
AND NOBODY SAYS ANYTHING, NOBODY
PUSHES BACK AS IF THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES TO TALKING THAT WAY
BUT THERE ARE.
HOW LONG CAN PEOPLE KEEP TALKING
LIKE THAT AND KEEP ACTING LIKE
THAT, IRRESPONSIBLY, CRAZY
BEFORE SOMETHING BREAKS?
BEFORE ONE OF THOSE
7,400,000,000 TERRORIST
TROTSKYITE RECORDS WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT TO BECOME SO
OVERWROUGHT AND PARANOID FROM
WATCHING DEMAGOGUES LIKE JAMAAL
BOWMAN ATTACK THEM ON MSNBC,
SOMETHING TRULY AWFUL THAT CAN’T
BE TAKEN BACK AND THE CYCLE
ACCELERATES RADICALLY AND AN
AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE GET HURT.
THAT’S WHERE THIS IS GOING,
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT, THAT’S
WHERE THIS WILL GO UNTIL AND
UNLESS SOMEONE RESPONSIBLE
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
APPEARS AND PUTS A STOP TO IT
AND SOON.
IT’S TIME FOR THE VICTORS TO
ACCEPT THEIR VICTORY, TO FORGIVE
THE TEAM THEY BEAT, AND TO MOVE
ON -- YOU WON!